um hi everyone my name is Eleanor um like
they said in the introduction I am a full
stack software engineer and today I'm going to
be talking to you about how to fail successfully
so by that I mean how to overcome your fear
of failure as a software engineering intern
so a little more background about me um like they
said I'm a full stack engineer the company I work
at is called fellow.app it's based in Ottawa
Canada and I've only been full-time there for
about the last nine months I started in January
before that I was an intern for a while and so
the experience of being an intern is still very
fresh with me it's still less than a year since
then and before I was an internet fellow I
interned at three other software companies
during my software engineering degree and
so I've had many News starts with different
companies and different code bases and it's been
my experience that being a new employee at a new
company with all this new information coming in is
a common situation for imposter syndrome to set in
there aren't many things in Tech that I think I'm
an expert in yet but I think that I have enough
first-hand experience with imposter syndrome to
talk about it with you today my experience with
imposter syndrome even included preparing for this
talk so I'm very well versed in what it feels like
so let's define our terms what is imposter
syndrome the basis of imposter syndrome is
the fear of being found out it's this idea
that somehow you have convinced everyone
around you you are a lot more qualified than
you actually are and the only way that you can
really combat this at least in my experience
is just getting used to your skill set getting
comfortable in it and learning more so that
you can get used to like what you actually know
and unfortunately in that process you're going
to have to get used to asking for help you're
going to make a lot of mistakes and you're
going to have to get used to saying I don't
know however if you're experiencing imposter
syndrome all of these things are going to
feel like personal failures which is why I call
overcoming them failing successfully so let's
take a step back and talk a little bit about what
it's like being an intern and the reason I want
to do this is that although I want to Target this
talk to people who are current interns and people
who are looking to be interned soon it's also
important I think to address this to managers
and people who are co-workers of current
interns because they're still very relevant
however if you're a manager or a team lead or
a senior engineer it's likely that you haven't
been an intern for quite some time so I want to
take a sec just to remind you what that's like
so this is my personal experience of course um
in my degree I worked really hard I didn't love
being a student but I still did all the work all
the assignments as best as I could to get good
grades and I studied really hard for interviews
that meant doing all the leetcode problems or
whatever else you have to do to study for those
and so by doing all this studying and background
stuff I felt like I actually knew a lot of
theory I felt like I was well versed in software
engineering and I could accomplish a lot so I
had confidence going into the jobs however if
the job have show up on the first day and the
job uses technologies that I'm unfamiliar with
then you start to sort of doubt yourself you
start to wonder maybe I actually know nothing
because when you are starting out a new job
you are limited to the technologies that your
employer uses and that might mean you can't
show them everything that you're capable of
for instance at fellow this was after five years
of engineering school but I wasn't very good at
react I hadn't used react very much so all of my
engineering knowledge all of this random Theory
and algorithms and stuff that I could talk about
it was all narrowed down into whether or not I
could actually build a good react component and
I really couldn't I didn't know a lot of react
so that's when I started to doubt myself and
that's when imposter syndrome starts to set in
something I think is important when you are hiring
interns is making sure that you're assigning the
meaningful projects there is this management
Theory I think it's called management Theory X
and Y and there's a whole bunch to it I won't
go into it because I'm not a business student
but essentially it boils down to the fact that
people will work the way they are expected to so
if you micromanage people and you treat them as
though they are going to mess up and you don't
give them much responsibility because you don't
want them to cause any problems then that is the
level at which they're going to work at they're
probably not going to be very interested in doing
good work because they're going to feel like you
expect them to fail but if you give them a lot
more room to grow and you show them their opinions
and their ideas are valuable then it will let them
perform at a higher level and I think this is very
relevant to the idea of the intern project this is
something that I've experienced quite a lot when
I say the intern project I mean like a small side
project or menial tasks that are assigned to
interns so they don't mess with the larger
code base or they don't delete customer data they
don't cause bugs on production however if you are
an intern working on the intern project you can
sort of tell that the tasks that you're doing are
meaningless and it will really enforce any kind of
imposter syndrome that you're already experiencing
furthermore if you are just working alone on
this project which was my experience a few
times it means that you're isolated and you
can't learn from other people around you you
can't learn from your teammates you can't
learn from their reviews and other things
which is something that's really important
as an intern one of the most valuable things
you can get from an internship is other people's
input and advice because that's what you'll learn
I actually worked at a company one time where I
was my entire scrum team because I was entirely on
my own intern project and so if I'd been following
their scrum practices exactly I was my own scrum
master and I would have had to sit down by myself
every morning and have a stand up to talk about
my project but obviously that's ridiculous
and I didn't do it but that was really the
structure that I was working along and I didn't I
didn't learn anything in that internship because
I was just regurgitating my existing knowledge
and I didn't have any reason to build on that
so as managers it is important to assign interns
low urgency High importance projects this is a
term that my manager uses and she's great with
interns um and when I say low urgency I mean
if it goes over time or if it goes over budget
it's not a big deal it's okay it's not a very
high stress environment if the intern makes a
mistake that's all right you can take the time
to fix it it's not very serious however the work
that they're producing is important enough that
they can see it reflected in the end product
they can see how it impacts the end users how
it is valuable to the company and that's really
really important when you're an intern because
it will motivate you to do better work and it will
help you decrease any existing imposter syndrome
so now that I've talked about being an intern a
little bit you're probably wondering that's all
great but how can I fail successfully how can I
overcome my fear of failure and fail successfully
so first point ask for help I know that
is pretty straightforward but it is it
sort of boils down to the belief that it
is okay to not know everything it's okay
to admit that you need help sometimes as an
intern you aren't going to know everything
the the way that I think about asking for help
is that the sooner that you realize that you are
stuck in a position you're up against a wall
you have tried everything but you just can't
make something work the sooner you realize that
you're in that position the sooner you can ask
for help and overcome that and just continue
working because if you do that very quickly
it's less time stuck in that position of feeling
like you don't know anything and you're worried
to ask for help and the longer you sustain
that the more imposter syndrome is going to
fit in so if you can realize you're stuck ask
for help carry on it's like nothing happened
I actually have a story my first time my first
week at fellow I was assigned some very basic
tickets at least I assumed they were basic and
I got stuck because I wasn't very familiar with
react so I was having trouble navigating the code
base and also I couldn't figure out the framework
we were using it's called Pros mirror if anyone's
familiar with it it's for document collaboration
and I started to really doubt myself
in this position because again five
years engineering experience you know I
couldn't complete these really basic tasks
but I was comparing myself as well to the other
intern who I knew was really good at react so
that didn't help anything and we were working on
the same tickets and I knew that he was probably
just killing them just doing great and I was not
able to do anything at all and So eventually I
realized I wasn't going to be able to make any
progress on these and I realized that the best
person to ask for help was actually going to be
the other intern and this was really hard for me
because I didn't want to admit admit that I needed
help from the other person that was supposed to be
at the same level as I was but I had to swallow
my pride and realize that I needed help so I
asked him I messaged him very cautiously on slack
and I said hey I'm stuck and luckily he said yeah
thank God I'm also really confused this code makes
no sense and I was so relieved and we were able
to work together and complete the tickets it all
turned out great but it really helped my imposter
syndrome to know that I wasn't the only one
feeling confused and I never would have come to
that realization if I hadn't reached out and asked
for help and also it was really helpful to know
that I was actually capable of completing the work
that I was assigned even though it meant having
to collaborate with someone else I was still
capable I could still do things in that position
so as an intern what are some things that we can
do to make it less scary to ask for help because
it is an intimidating thing to do something
that's really helped me whenever I ask for help
is presenting questions in the context of what I
already do know so by that I mean if you're saying
hey I'm stuck this is the error message I got can
you fix it that feels like you're admitting that
you can't do anything but instead if you say hey I
was writing this function I got stuck at this line
because I wasn't sure about this whatever other
function I'm calling I've tried x y and Zed I've
read this documentation I'm just stuck about this
little part can you explain that to me that first
of all is going to make it a lot easier for the
other person to answer your question but also
it's going to make it feel less as though you're
admitting that you don't know things because you
are telling them all of the things that you do
know you're just missing one puzzle piece that
maybe they can provide you with secondly like
I've said before always remember that no one in
software knows everything when you're new to the
industry it might feel like you're surrounded by
people who know so much stuff but realistically
it is a massive world and it's impossible for
everyone in software to know everything about
everything so as a team what can you do to
help interns feel less intimidated asking for
help I think this is underrated but encouraging
collaborations socializing within a team is really
helpful because instead of asking people who are
complete strangers for help you can ask someone
that you might think is your friend or you have
some degree of personal connection with and that
makes it a lot easier because at least you have a
basis with that person to work off of as opposed
to just approaching someone out of the blue
and finally when you are answering questions if
possible I think it's really helpful to provide
guidance as opposed to just a solution so you
don't even necessarily have to give a straight
answer you can say hey have you checked out these
docs have you read this article have you looked
in this file at this function have you seen what
this other person wrote about it because that way
the intern will actually or whoever's asking the
question will actually learn something from that
answer as opposed to just getting a block of code
back because you just send them a block of code
you're probably going to get that same question a
week later because they haven't learned anything
from it but if you can provide them guidance
it will be really helpful for both of you
secondly uh you can really help imposter
syndrome is very scary because the idea
of making mistakes is one of the worst things
that could possibly happen in that scenario and
unfortunately you are going to make mistakes
it is going to happen and that's really all
there is to it you just have to get used to
the idea that you are going to make mistakes
um it doesn't mean that you aren't qualified it
doesn't mean that you're doing something wrong
it's just something that happens sometimes so
what can we do to come to terms with this idea
well uh just make the most of it I know that's
a cliche I know that's uh you know it might seem
obvious but it is sometimes difficult and I have
a story that I think about every day pretty much
of a silly mistake I made a long time ago I was
at a cafe I was making my coffee they'd given
it to me and I was trying to figure out where
the sugar Shaker was because I like sugar in my
coffee and so I put what I thought was sugar in my
coffee and the Barista turns around and says why
are you putting salt in your coffee why would you
want that and instead of acknowledging that I had
made a mistake and that I had done something wrong
I said no actually I love salt in my coffee I am
just gonna take this thank you though and I went
and I had the nastiest drink of my whole life just
because I was too proud or embarrassed or awkward
to admit that I had made a very innocent mistake
and I could have just said can I have a new
coffee instead but I didn't I don't know why
but I just couldn't do it in that moment and this
I want to use as an analogy here because it's very
it would seem to be very easy to say hey I did
something wrong this was silly I don't know why
I did that but can you help me can we can we
fix this together because it would be so easy
just to make me a new coffee but in that moment
that was the hardest thing to do in the world
so mistakes will happen in a variety of scenarios
we're all human we all make mistakes all day long
and unfortunately you spend a lot of your
time at work and so you're going to make
a decent percentage of your mistakes at work
and the best you can really do is try to make
the most of it in this situation and move
on and hope that it doesn't happen again
do everything you can to learn from it and put it
in place so that you hope it doesn't happen again
there are a few things that I think we can do
as management to make it less scary and make it
less likely that serious mistakes will happen
at work first I really hope no one is actually
doing this but don't encourage a culture of
blame I think that when a serious like let's
say worst case scenario a major bug goes to
production your first instinct shouldn't be
okay let's point fingers let's figure out whose
fault this was who can we pin the blame on your
instinct should be instead let's collectively
figure out how we can solve this issue and that
will make it easier for whoever it was maybe
someone was actually responsible for this bug
it will make it easier for them to figure help
you figure out what went wrong as opposed to them
being too scared to mention anything because
they're worried of having the blame on them
secondly I've always been really inspired
by managers that I've had who've admitted
to times that they've made serious mistakes
because it helps me realize that it's very
human to do so and you can rise through the
ranks you can still have a successful career
and have made mistakes in the past and finally
for everyone's peace of mind there are a lot
of software processes that you can put around
your development life cycle like Ci pipelines
or just stringent review processes so that the
worst mistakes don't actually make it that far
I think this will really help everyone feel a
little more safe with the idea of making mistakes
so finally my biggest point is saying I don't know
and I know this sounds a little counter-intuitive
but I don't mean just say I don't know everywhere
all the time but be confident in what you do
know but also be transparent in what that
limit is and what you still need to learn
so by that I mean know what you know and what
you don't know and like I said this might be
counterintuitive it might feel like you're
admitting as though you're under qualified
or unintelligent but if you can genuinely
sit down with yourself and figure out what
you do know about a topic if you can Define this
boundary of this is what I do know and figure out
your the limits of your knowledge once you
establish that you can be very transparent
with people when you're talking with them
about what you don't know and it will feel
less like an admittance of some personal
failure because you've established look
this is all the stuff that I do know that
just happens to be outside of this range
plus it will help with imposter syndrome because
imposter syndrome is telling you that everyone
believes you know a lot more than you do but if
you can be honest and say hey this is what I do
know this is what I don't know it's really
impossible for imposter syndrome to tell you
that you are making something up or that people
are convinced you're more qualified than you are
this is really helpful when responding to
questions feedback and criticism this was
a situation that used to give me a lot of anxiety
because first I was worried that people would ask
me questions I didn't know the answer to or
that they would point out things that I did
wrong while I was presenting to everybody but if
you can remember why you think you're right why
you made the decisions when you're coding and also
be transparent about what you have left to learn
it makes it really decreases your anxiety in that
environment and it makes you feel less defensive
when people ask you questions or suggest that
maybe you could have done something differently
when people do maybe they ask you a question say
hey why did you use this approach instead of that
one you can discuss your thought process instead
of being like oh they they think I'm doing it
wrong they think I made a mistake you can say hey
this is why I did it this way I appreciate your
input maybe we can figure out a better solution
together you can be curious about their input and
you can collaborate on a new solution something
that's helped me as an intern in these situations
where people are asking me questions is just
practicing being again very transparent and
saying very simple things like can't you clarify
what you mean maybe they asked a really confusing
question you need more context or that's a really
good point I hadn't thought about it like that or
just I don't know is a valid answer it is quite
possible someone asks you a question and you don't
know the answer to it and that's all right in that
moment you shouldn't make up an answer that sounds
right which is something that I used to try to do
it doesn't that doesn't benefit anybody the most
efficient thing to do in that moment is
just to say I don't know I can find out
later I will let you know but right now I
don't know and that's honestly that's okay
and on the topic of remembering why you think
you're right don't assume that other people
are always right even if you feel like you aren't
very qualified there are there are a lot of ways
that other people might seem right that aren't
actually the case one of them is just confusing
code that you might come across so uh something
that happened to me recently was at work we had
this code that was supposed to Cache values
that were returned from an API to avoid excess
API calls and I knew that we did this I knew
why we did it and I was building a new feature
on some of the old code and I couldn't figure
out why we weren't caching the values there
and I assumed that I misunderstood it and that we
should have been caching or that yeah we shouldn't
have been caching but I was I was doing something
wrong and so I was stuck with this for a while and
eventually I had to go ask the developer who built
the code I said hey why aren't we doing that here
and he said oh yeah you're totally right
we should be cashing there we just missed
it in that spot and I felt so silly because I
could have just added that code I could have
just realized we should have been doing this
here the code is wrong I can add that feature
but instead I was convinced that I was I
was doing something wrong in that moment
secondly I think it's a stereotype that's
absolutely true is that Engineers really love
to have strong opinions and that's okay but when
someone comes to you with a really strong opinion
and you're experiencing imposter syndrome it might
be easy to feel as though they're telling you that
you're wrong so sometimes it's good to step back
and consider is the reproach actually better what
they're suggesting or are they just trying to
say it louder so they have something to say
and finally take their take their opinion
into account that's totally fine they might
be giving you valuable feedback but also if you
can remember everything that you do know you can
add it onto that instead of just overriding it
with someone else's opinion and finally I think
that it's important to note that everything in my
presentation so far is going to be a lot stronger
with people who are part of underrepresented
groups in software engineering so for instance
me as a woman in software engineering I have a
lot of fear of confirming stereotypes that people
might have about women in engineering and the only
way that I really found to counteract that is by
having diverse representation in management right
now I have a female manager her name is Alexandra
sunderlin she just wrote a book it's called
remote Engineering Management she's great if
you want to check her out but having that diverse
representation in management really made me feel
as though I had someone that I could look up to
who I saw myself in and I could see them being
assertive and making decisions and being respected
in the company it made it feel like it was okay
for me to be part of this underrepresented
group as well in software engineering
so you're wondering maybe whether I follow my own
advice I do as much as really anyone can I think
for instance I'm always seeking opportunities to
feel more confident in my skills by exiting my
comfort zone for instance flying from Canada to
Korea today to talk to you about all this this
is hugely out of my comfort zone but here I am
anyway uh something that's really helpful for me
is being transparent about what I do and what I
don't know when I'm responding to questions that
has helped me immensely in combating imposter
syndrome is just being very straightforward
about the things that I'm confident in and the
things that I have left to learn and finally
always asking for help and clarification when I
realized that I need it and again that might seem
obvious but it's much easier to do that than just
be stuck in that position feeling too embarrassed
by the fact that you don't know something so
finally if you have any takeaways here please
remember to ask for help make mistakes
and say I don't know thank you very much